[Music]
imagine being able to travel to any
point in time
where would you go and what would you do
you could witness some of the greatest
moments in history
or even change history you could
travel into the future or you could even
save john f kennedy from being
assassinated
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you owned a time machine
so how could we travel through time
well no one that we know of has figured
this out yet but
physicists have a couple of theories
about how we might do this
it can involve us either traveling at
the speed of light
jumping through a black hole or some
other crazy method
and yes though it is theoretically
impossible to travel back in time
let's just say we can do it anyway oh
and
also we won't be jumping through any
black holes
instead we're giving you a magical
pocket time machine that can take you to
any point in time so what's your first
stop
naturally you'd probably want to go to
some of the most critical moments in
human history
maybe you'd want to go to world war ii
and see what it was really like
you could prevent things like pearl
harbor from ever happening by
informing the americans that the
japanese are going to attack
it's unlikely they'll believe you
considering you're a complete stranger
but
who knows if successful you could end up
saving millions of lives
or if you're not that bold you could
just sit back and
live in the world grab a drink with some
soldiers or
just hang out in the 1940s and avoid the
war altogether
for our next stop let's go help tear
down the berlin wall
you won't necessarily be influencing
this part of history but
you'll certainly be a part of it how
cool is that
and after this we can go further back in
time
to paris in the late 1800s
then let's jump forward a bit and hang
out with the beatles
now that was all fun and good but it's
probably time to head back to your
current day
but when you get back you notice that
the world looks a bit different
earthquakes are happening radiation is
everywhere and
cities are completely destroyed you're
now living in an apocalypse
this is due to the butterfly effect you
may have heard of this before
the classic example is that a butterfly
on one side of the world in the jurassic
age
can cause a tornado to happen in 2004
now obviously butterfly wings can't
directly cause a tornado
but this example shows that all actions
in the past
have consequences in the future no
matter how big or little
all actions will ripple through space
and time
of course killing baby hitler or showing
people cell phones in the past before
they're invented
will greatly impact the future that much
is obvious when we look at huge turning
points in history
what's not so obvious is the idea that
any little thing we do
impacts the future so let's say we don't
participate in world war ii
or stop any crazy events from happening
we just go to the past and
simply observe walk around maybe even
buy a coffee
when we come back to our current time
things might still look vastly different
than when you left
if you simply exist in the past it can
alter and change things in the future
no matter how little you do here's an
example of the butterfly effect
potentially at work in our real world
the u.s rail system is an oddly specific
size of four feet and eight and a half
inches wide
why is that well the people who built
the railroads were used to making wagons
that were that size
the wagons originally came from england
where they made them that specific
size due to grooves in the road if the
wagons were any wider
they could get damaged so they settled
on four feet eight and a half inches
the reason the roads were this way was
because two thousand years before this
roman chariots made these first roads as
they were conquering the area
and the reason the chariots were this
size because it was the size needed for
two horses to fit
on a single chariot so when you think
about the reason
the united states has railroads like
this it's because of horses
more specifically the size of their
butts
this just goes to show how decisions we
made in the past
no matter how little or inconsequential
they might seem
could seriously change the future we can
also think of it
as the decisions we're making right now
will greatly impact the future
so what if watching this video today is
preventing a world war
hundreds of years from now and
what if instead of being a time traveler
you met one well that sounds like a
story
for another what if